ces images vous les avez peut-être vu
depuis hier et vous vous demandez ce
qu'elles représentent elles ont été
prises par le télescope spatial Euclide
et dévoilé par l'Agence spatiale
européenne et pour en parler pour les
décrypter pour vous expliquer ce qu'on
voit sur ces images et bien je suis avec
Tristan V bonjour Tristan bonjour merci
d'être avec nous aujourd'hui pour parler
de ce sujet de ces de de de ces images
j'invite bien sûr à poser leurs
questions on est sur YouTube sur le site
du Figaro on y répond comme d'habitude
euh globalement qu'est-ce que montrent
ces images qu'est-ce qu'est-ce que ce
sont des grandes découvertes alors en
fait ces images c'est les premières imag
du télescope spatial européen qui
s'appelle Euclide qui est un télescope
qui a été lancé fin juin toute fin juin
par l'Agence spatiale européenne et
c'est ce qu'on appelle un enin ce qu'on
appelle ce qu'on pourrait appeler un
télescope cosmologique ou un télescope
dédié c'està qu'en fait il a une mission
principale particulière qui est de faire
une cartographie de la matière noire et
de l'énergie noire dans le dans
l'univers pour faire cette cartographie
il a besoin de mesurer en fait très
précisément la position de de de plein
de de galaxies de mesurer leur forme et
les très légère déformation de leur
formme vont être lié à la matière noire
qui a sur la ligne de Visé on pourra
revenir sur ce que c'est la matière
noire no d'énergie noire et de matière
noire il va falloir expliquer à nos
internautes de quoi il s'agit on va
revenir dessus et du coup donc pour
faire ça il a besoin de de voir donc des
tas et des tas de galaxies mais quand je
distas c'est des milliards de galaxies
euh sur quasiment l'intégralité du ciel
il va couvrir à peu près un/ers de de la
voûe céleste en gros toute la voûe
céleste une fois qu'on a enlevé la Voie
Lactée parce que la Voie Lactée donc
qu'on voit dans le ciel elle nous bloque
un peu la vue de l'univers lointain trop
lumineuse trop lumineuse et voilà une
fois qu'on a enlevé aussi le bon
certaines différentes zones de de la
Voie Lactée où il y a des bref il y a
environ de tiers du ciel qui qui est qui
est pas très bon pour faire ce genre
d'observation et donc qu'on on regarde
le tiers profond du reste du ciel et
c'est là qu'on va faire ce gigantesque
relevé et donc là ça va prendre du temps
ça va prendre plusieurs années et là
quelques mois après le lancement les
scientifiques ont voulu montrer que le
télescope marché avec ses performances
nominales et donc ils ont sorti une
série de de cinq images pour faire la
démonstration des performances de
l'instrument et c'est des super c'est
vraiment enfin moi je des très très
belles images c'est pas forcément
évident de comprendre pourquoi elles
sont aussi belles ou pourquoi elles sont
aussi exceptionnelles on va peut-être
pvoir l'expliquer ici mais l'idée
générale c'est ça c'est cinq images pour
démontrer que l'instrument marche super
bien et maintenant il va rentrer dans
une longue phase de relevé systématique
on aura probablement plus d'images ou
c'est pas comme le James web qui lui
fait des observations ponctuelles de
plein d'objets ou Hubble qui faisait ça
là c'est vraiment un télescope qui va
faire un relevé au long cours et dont on
a'ura pas de nouvelles pendant un
certain moment et ces images qu'on nous
a montré sont
essentiellement là pour nous montrer que
ça marche très bien alors il y a de la
science qui pourra en sortir parce que
les performances de l'instrument sont
telles que voilà il y a y a les astromes
peuvent déjà tirer des choses de ces
images là mais c'est pas le but de la la
mission première ça c'est quelque chose
qui se fera dans un deuxième temps une
fois qu'il aura ce relevé gigantesque du
ciel les scientifiques pourront
exploiter les données pendant des années
des années pour aller ensuite voir
d'autres phénomènes plus particuliers
plus ponctuels là c'est un peu l'étape
communication regarder on a réussi notre
télescope marche en fait c'est ça c'est
c'est on a c'est et puis voilà donc
c'est après il il y a quand même cinq
projets scientifiques derrière c'est qu'
y a eu
CIN cibles qui ont été choisies avec des
objectifs scientifiques voilà histoire
de pas faire ça pour rien entre
guillemets
euh donc il y a quand même un intérêt
scientifique mais c'est clairement pas
le but du télescope le but du télescope
c'est vraiment de faire se relever
systématique pour faire cette
cartographie sauf que pour faire cette
cartographie de l'énergie de la matière
noire on a besoin de performance
exception INELL et et voilà et donc là
le le le técope les a atteint c'est
d'autant plus important de le montrer
qu'il y a eu des petites des petits
soucis pendant le c'est c'est quelques
mois de ce qu'on appelle le
commissioning la la la recette en vol
c'est la période pendant laquelle en
gros les ingénieurs regardent si le
télescope fonctionne correctement euh et
donc il y a eu des petits problèmes avec
ce qu' a un système qui s'appelle le
fine guiding sensor qui est un espèce de
système de pointage très fin en gros le
satellite se repère avec quelques
étoiles euh dans le ciel ce qui lui
permet de suivre de de de rester très
très stable pour pouvoir effectuer ces
images extrêmement précises et donc ce
petit système avait des ce ce système
avait des petits euh euh soucis sur
lequel on pourra revenir si vous voulez
mais qui soit un peu un un détail mais
en gros qui empêchait de faire certains
pointer très précis et donc il a fallu
apporter un correctif logiciel euh et
voilà donc le correctif logiciel a
marché ce qui a permis de réaliser ces
images il y a juste une 6e image qu'on
aurait dû avoir qu'on n' pas pu avoir
liée à ce petit retard euh lié au f au
fjs mais est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on aura
bientôt du coup cette 6e image ou est-ce
que je crois qu'elle est du coup elle
est annulé pour l'instant elle est
annulée après c'est c'est c'est une
image de de ce qu'on appelle un arc
gravitationnel donc c'est un comment
dire c'est c'est c'est une
déformation liée à à la présence d'une
grande masse sur la ligne de Visé qui
provoque une espèce un espèce de mirage
gravitationnel et donc ça crée un petit
arc de lumière et voilà et là Essie de
faire une très belle image de cet arc
pour montrer qu'on qu'on arrivit très
bien à voir ça parce que c'est euh la la
la détection en gros de toutes les
perturbations gravitationnelles c'est un
peu la clé de ce que va faire Euclide
donc voilà ça aurait été chouette de
laavir et euh et mais c'est pas très
grave parce qu'il y en aura des aration
comme ça ils vont probablement en
trouver des centaines de milliers au
cours du relevé donc c'est bon c'est
c'est c'est pas très très grave de pas
en avoir un tout de suite il y en aura
des il y en aura des encore une fois des
centaines de milliers pendant le cours
du relevé donc c'est juste que voilà ça
aurait été bien pour la comm de le
l'avoir là on on aura dans un an une
nouvelle publication d'images parce que
dans un an il y a la première partie du
relevé qui est terminé tout est très
prévu à l'avance donc en gros là il y a
un an de prise de données au bout d'un
an de prise de données donc il aura ils
vont montrer quelques images de cette
première année de de relevé et un an
plus tard on aura les publications
scientifiques sur cette première année
de relevé donc les premiers résultats
scientifiques importants de CIDE ce sera
en décembre 2025 euh et voilà donc il
aura un petit releas dans un an histoire
en gros de faire patienter un peu les
gens et de de dire voilà on a fait la
première année de releveveré c'est bien
passé et dans un an vous aurez le
résultat de cette première année de
relevée sachant que pant cette année où
ils vont étudier les premières années
données ils vont prendre encore des
données et cetera et cetera et ça va ça
va séchelonner sur je crois que c'est 8
ans je crois pour le relev complet pour
le relev complet Euclide et après il y
aura ce qu'on appelle la partie Legacy
science c'estàd la mise à disposition de
toutes les données prises pendant ces
ces années pour d'autres chercheur pour
voilà toute la communauté et donc du
coup ça va être une espèce de de bible
de de galaxie on va vraiment avoir une
cartographie enfin c'est c'est c'est dur
de se rendre compte mais moi j'ai du mal
à me à réaliser mais euh c'est c'est on
parle de milliards de galaxies qui vont
être identifié cartographié qu' dit
quand quand vous dites que un tiers de
l'univers va être cartographi c'est
quand
même ouais alors c'est un tir de la voûe
céleste la voûe céleste pardon et après
euh donc dans cette voûe céleste après
on regarde en en profondeur et donc là
l'idée c'est de regarder jusqu'à environ
10 milliards d'années lumières alors
c'est toujours un peu on regarde enfin
en fait on on on va identifier la
lumière qui a mis 10 milliards d'années
à nous parvenir donc on quand on regarde
dans dans l'espace en fait on regarde
dans un espèce de de de de cône
euh qui va regarder de plus en plus loin
euh dans le passé donc on regarde à la
fois loin loin dans le passé il y a pas
il y a pas vraiment de distinction euh
euh en en astronomie entre le regarder
loin et regarder loin dans le temps
d'accord c'est un peu la la même chose
donc c'est un peu perturbant pour le
pour l'esprit euh
mais c'est c'est c'est l'idée générale
là sur cette image qu'on voit que vous
avez
ici c'est c'est donc c'est un ce qu'on
voit les points très lumineux les allo
c'est c'est un super c'est un H qu'on
appelle Lama de
Percé et là sur cette image là on voit
un millier en fait à peu près de de
galaxies de premier plan alors celle où
vous voyez des petites croix lumineuse
la diffraction ça c'est des étoiles de
notre Voie Lactée des étoiles
d'avant-plan d'accord vous don une idée
de la profondeur donc ça c'est des
images d'avant-plan les toutes celle où
vous voyez des ces petites étoiles à six
branches ça c'est des étoiles c'est le
la figure de diffraction qui est lié au
à l'instrument
elle-même et donc ça c'est les étoiles
ponctuelles d'avant-plan qui sont dans
notre VO lacté
ensuite au plan suivant vous avez donc
Lama qui est situé à 240 millions
d'années lumière qui est donc un
rassemblement de galaxie très dense et
là il y aprs environ un millier de ces
objets donc c'est c'est c'est dur de se
rendre compte mais il y a il y en a un
millier parmi tous les points que vous
voyez il y en a un millier qui qui font
partie de cet as qui s'étend voilà qui a
une certaine c'estàdire que si on avait
un parce que une étoile on a le soleil
c'est une étoile jusque là là-dedans il
y a combien de soleil des milliards
d'accord voilà et alors ce qui est assez
marrant c'est là celui que tu pointes
celui que tu pointes par exemple c'est
c'est ceux qui sont c'est à l' lumineux
il a en fait une galaxie au centre et le
halo lumineux on a l'impression que
c'est comme comme un peu le le le halo
d'un lampadaire en fait c'est pas
exactement ça en fait c'est juste que
les les galaxies sont tellement en
interaction gravitationnelle les unes
avec les autres qu'elles s'arrachent des
étoiles et donc c'est des étoiles en
fait qui sont qui sont entre guillemets
vagabondes un peu entre les galaxies
donc c'est c'est vraiment des hos
d'étoil c'est pas c'est pas un effet de
d'éblouissement du c'est parce qu'il y
il y en a tellement qui bougent à droite
à gauche parce que çame un al un allo
d'étoile autour de la Galaxie par
qu'elles ont été arraché un peu par la
gravitation comme elles sont comme il y
a beaucoup de galaxies qui sont entre
elles ell elles se passent les unes à
côté des autres elles s'arrachent un peu
des étoiles qui restent attaché à la
galaxie mais du coup dans un peu plus
lointaine et du coup ça forme une espèce
de de voilà mais en fait c'est vraiment
des étoiles quoi on arrive pas à les
distinguer elles sont trop lointaines si
vous voulez pour les distinguer une à
une mais mais on arrive à voir le
lumière collective qui donne ces àau et
donc là il y a env un millier et
derrière si vous zoomez encore vous avez
les galaxies d'arrière-plan et là c'est
des galaxies qui peuvent être à un
milliard d'années lumièr jusqu'à plus de
enfin alors elles sont elles sont encore
plus loin aujourd'hui mais c'est des
galaxies dont la lumière a mis un
milliard d'années à nous parvenir
jusqu'à 10 milliards d'années à nous
parvenir oui parce que vous dit tout à
l'heure c'est qu'en fait pour savoir où
sont ces
enfin on réussit avec la vitesse de la
lumière à savoir où sont les choses SAF
que la vitesse de la lumière met du
temps à arriver en fait on voit l'objet
tel qu'il était il y a 10 milliards
d'années aujourd'hui est-ce que ça a un
sens de dire où il est aujourd'hui je
sais pas exactement mais il il a évolué
depuis des milliards d'années mais petit
à petit c'est voilà nous les photons
qu'on reçoit ont 10 milliards d'années
donc on peut le voir C galaxie que tel
qu'elles étaient il y a y a 10 milliards
d'années donc elles sont pas vraiment on
peut dire qu'elles sont à 10 milliards
d'Ann la lumière qui nous en parvient 10
milliards d'années à nous parvenir donc
on dit des fois qu'elles sont ad les
lumière par abus de langage en réalité
elles sont plus là elles sont elles se
sont éloignées l'univers s'étend bref
c'est c'est compliqué c'est ces galaxies
d'arrière-plan sur cette seule image il
y en a 100000 c'est dur de se rendre
compte en fait là nous l'image qu'on a
là est de d'assez bonne qualité on peut
zoomer
dedans la vraie image elle est encore 10
fois plus profonde elle fait 64000
pixels de côté et quand on zoom on zoom
on zoom on continue à voir encore de
nouvelles de nouveaux petits points donc
il y a 100000 galaxies d'arrière-plan
pour vous donner un un un un ordre de
grandeur de de la du nombre que ça
représente sur un ciel super étoilé que
vous voyez magnifique vous êtes je sais
pas la campagne vous avez un St dit ah
j'ai jamais vu autant d'étoiles il y a
3000 étoiles à peu près et là 100000 et
là il y en a 100000 sur cette seule
image donc c'est bon c'est voilà c'est
c'est c'est c'est complètement
incroyable et peut-être plus incroyable
encore alors ça c'est mon mon côté un
peu mais pour faire cette image vous
avez peut-être vu des connu des des gens
autour de vous qui sont astronomes
amateurs qui prennent des des photos et
qui font une super photo de Galaxy bah
ils ont généralement pointé l'objet
plusieurs nuits ils ont accumulé
observations pour récupérer les photons
petit à petit et cetera donc Hubble de
la mme manière faisait des pauses
longues ou alors multiplier les les
champs euh là pour faire cette image il
a fallu 5 heur voilà il a il a et
l'image est gigantesque Hubble il lui
aurait fallu des années pour pouvoir
couvrir toute cette zone de ciel parce
que Hubble était aussi précis à peu près
queclide mais il était capable de faire
des portions de ciel minuscules
euh vra que ce qui a réussi c'est ce que
finalement a fait Hubble en 20 ans alors
peut-être pas en 20 ans mais en quelques
années au moins en quelques en quelques
il aur fallu quelques années à Hubble
pour produire cette image en y passant
tout son
temps et là il a fau 5 heur à euclid
pour le faire parce qu'en fait Euclide
ça son énorme force ça on pourend parler
sur les un peu sur les autres images qui
sont peut-être moins impressionnantes
immédiatement mais B qu's sont pour des
pour des pour les spécialistes
euh c'est que il a un champ un champ de
vue extrêmement large plusieurs fois la
la taille de la pleine lune
euh et c'est ça qui va lui qui lui
permettre de faire la cartographie de
milliards d'objets c'est que il voit à
la fois très précisément sur une zone de
ciel très très grande alors ça c'est la
deuxième image justement c'est la
deuxième image alors par une galaxie
spirale c'est une galaxie spirale qu'on
a qu'on qu'on appelle parfois la galaxie
cachée on peut on comprend pas très bien
pourquoi on l'appelle la galaxie cachée
quand cette image là fa voir les images
de Hubble en fait elle est est pleine de
poussière les les images qu'on pou avir
aveble par exemple on voit que un un
tout petit bout de cette galaxie parce
qu'elle est trop proche elle est à je
crois 11 années lumière 11 millions
d'années lumièr de nous euh donc ce qui
déjà très loin ce qui est loin mais
relativement proche elle elle prend une
grosse place dans le ciel par exemple
dans le ciel elle et elle présente
différentes difficultés elle est située
proche proche du du du plan galactique
donc elle est pas forcément facile à
observer on peut vite être Louis elle
est elle est très grande dans le ciel
très très ténue on la voit pas à l'œil
nu mais il faut en accumulant les le
temps d'observation elle finit par
apparaître petit à petit ses photons
finissent par apparaître elle occupe une
grande part de ciel donc avec un
télescope comme Hubble qui lui voit très
profondément mais des champs tout petit
on voit que une petite partie de la
galaxie n'arrive pas à la voir dans son
intégralité donc cette image elle est
impressionnante pour les spécialistes
pour ça parce que cette cette objet là
les astronomesateur ont fait des des des
des vues
relativement belles où on voit bien les
les bras spirireux dans son intégralité
mais là on arrive à voir je sais pas
tous les Allos laiteux et quand on zoome
dedans on voit les images les les
étoiles quasiment une par une ENF c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment super
impressionnant quoi la la voilà la
densité enfin voilà on voit les on voit
vraiment les étoiles une par une quoi
ENF
c'est ces petites taches bleues qui sont
à côté c'est des alors ça ça dépend
lesquels je pourrais pas vous dire
précisément pour chaque mais ça c'est
c'est souvent des des nuages
moléculaires qui sont illuminés par des
étoiles jeunes d'accord donc c'est des
c'est des des nuage de gaz et il y a des
étoiles jaunes très brillantes qui m
dans l'ultraviolet et souvent c'est ça
qui crée ces ces couleurs bleuté donc
après je pourrais pas vous dire
précisément pour chacune c'estes et mais
mais en gros l'idée c'est qu'avec cette
image là on peut et encore une fois là
on n' pas l'image pleine résolution la
pleine résolution elle est encore 10
fois mieux définie et là les chercheurs
vont pouvoir zoomer zoomer ils ont aussi
des informations de spectro dessus et
ils vont pouvoir du coup étudier la
dynamique en fait de cette galaxie étudé
quelles étoiles sont ensemble est-ce
qu'il y a des amas ce qu'on appelle des
amas globulaires qui sont des des des
amas d'étoiles qui se sont formé à
partir d'un même nuage qui s'est
effondré sur lui-même ils vont pouvoir
voir la des des choses dans la dans la
dynamique et et cette galaxie spirale
c'est en fait c'est comme notre voie
lacté si vous voulez sauf qu'on la voit
par le dessus nous notre voie lacté on
est dedans donc on la voit par la
tranche on peut pas la voir en fait
toutes les images que vous avez de notre
voie lacté avec des braspireau c'est en
fait d'autres galaxies c'est pas nous on
l' on pourra jamais voir notre galaxie
euh comme comme on la voit là donc c'est
très intéressant pour nous d'avoir un si
si on envoie un télescope au-dessus de
nous ou Mo le côté il faudrait il
faudrait pour sortir du plan galactique
des des des centaines de milliers
d'années en voyagant à la vitesse de la
lumière donc si déjà qu'on arrive pas à
aller à l'étoile la plus proche de nous
dans la galaxie qui a 4re années lumière
euh voilà des centaines de milliers
d'années lumière pour en sortir voilà
bon si un jour on découvre des
technologies complètement je sais pas
dans dans 10000 ans 20000 ans peut-être
qu'on pourra un jour mais actuellement
on arrive même pas à faire le saut de
puce qui nous permettrait de de passer
d'un d'un de ces minuscules points qu'on
voit dans ce de truc lu là à l'autre
c'est c'est totalement impossible
d'ailleurs eclide télescope spatial où
est-ce qu'il se trouve par rapport à la
Terre alors il se trouve avec avec le
télescope James web au point de deuxème
point de la grange donc qui se trouve en
fait alors il va falloir expliquer
points de la grange en fait il y a il y
a il y a quatre points d'équilibre
gravitationnel entre le Soleil et la
Terre un qui est assez entre guillemets
assez logiquement se situe entre la
terre et le soleil on peut bien imaginer
qu'il y a un point d'équilibre là mais
la mécanique orbitale l'tion d'instein
montre aussi qu'il y y a trois autres
points donc que si vous avez j'ess de
montrer si vous avez le soleil ici et la
terre là vous avez un point d'équilibre
entre les deux un devant la terre qui
qui tourne comme ça un derrière la terre
et un autre de l'autre côté du soleil et
ben les les les la plupart des
télescopes sont derrière dans ce point
derrière c'est que du coup ils sont à
l'ombre un peu le plus souvent à l'ombre
du pas tout le temps mais ils sont un
peu à l'ombre du soleil ce qui est mieux
ça plus de plus de de stabilité et donc
il tourne un peu autour de de ce point
de d'équilibre gravitationnel c'est un
point très il y a ga qui est là-bas il y
a le JWST il y a euh il y a maintenant
Euclide euh donc c'est à c'est à c'est à
1 ou 2 million de kilomètres de la Terre
je j'ai un petit doute sur le chiffre
mais je crois que c'est 1 million ou 2
million de kilomètr euh de la terre euh
voilà c'est à la fois euh
loin c'est quelque fois la distance
terlune quoi c'est pas non plus euh oui
mais c'est voilà on demande forcément il
est pas en orbiteour il est pas en
orbite autour de nous comme il était
Hubble Hubble il était à 400 ou 500 km
il tournait autour de la tête là là ils
sont vraiment parti beaucoup plus loin
parti beaucoup plus loin pour être plus
stable voilà ça offre pas mal de pas mal
de de de garantie alors on va regarder
cette cette troisième image sur une
autre galaxie est-ce que vous pouvez
alors j'ai ça je pense que c'est le
c'est c'est c'est la trème image la trè
donc c'est la
galaxie IR app une galaxie irrégulière
alors là pareil c'est un peu dur de se
rendre
compte à quel point cette image est et
étonnante en fait si tu peux dézoomer un
tout petit peu en fait ce qui ce qui est
ce qu'on arrivait pas du tout à faire
auparavant ça c'est une galaxie nen
irrégulière donc elle a une ça se voit
pas trop cette Photim qu'elle qu'elle
qu'elle a une forme à peu près à peu
près sphérique en vrai c'est assez
désordonné si on si on la voyait en 3D
on verrait que le les étoiles sont
réparties je va pas dire un peu
n'importe comment mais mais un peu voilà
il y a des espèces de courant d'étoil
c'est pas très c'est pas très ordonné
c'est pas une belle boule avec une
répartition aléatoire c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça mais voilà bref elle a
cette forme là et elle il y a plein
d'autres étoiles en à l'au autour et là
on arrive en fait à voir donc voilà on
le voit un peu là qu'il y a plein plein
d'étoiles autour voilà que ça ça on va
dire ça perd en densité mais il y a
quand même plein d'étoiles qui
appartiennent à cette galaxie nen don
c'est une galaxie qui tourne autour qui
est dans notre groupe local c'est notre
petit groupe de de galaxie et qui entre
guillemets tourne autour de notre VO
lacté bon c'est pas c'est un peu plus
bon mais en gros c'est une pour
simplifier c'est un de nos compagnons en
disant qu' on elles sont on va dire
qu'elles sont en interaction
gravitationnelle les unes avec les
autres elles sont elles sont li lié
entre elles elles sont liées entre elles
et et donc là c'est pareil en fait c'est
que le le on arrive à la fois à voir les
étoiles individuellement si on zoome là
dans dans stama qui a l'air un peu Laux
en fait on voit les étoiles une par une
c'est qu'on voilà c'est c'est et là
encore une fois tous ces petits points
voilà t tous ces petits
POS une sont étoil et ils sont résolus
c'estàdire que si on avec l'image à
CICAT qui donc 10 fois plus machin on
arrive encore à résoudre les points là
qui qui peuvent paraître un petit peu
floutés on arrive à les résoudre point
par point et donc avoir une information
spatiale sur leur distance et cetera et
donc on peut arriver après faire
conrtion 3D ce que vont faire les
astronomes et essayer de voir quel
groupe d'étoil pourqu elles sont
ensemble comment elles sont interaction
gravitationnelle c'est toutes ces études
là qui vont être mené sur ces donc on
arrive à la fois à avoir cette précision
à l'intérieur de la galaxie et avoir
toutes les toutes les étoiles qui sont
autour et comment elles interagissent
entre elles et en plus de ça on voit
encore dans le fond plein de galaxies
d'arrière-plan des milliers de galaxies
d'arrière-plan euh c'est c'est c'est
effectivement ce qu'on voit sur sur
cette image on peut regarder la la la la
4è image que je vais vous afficher tout
de suite qui est aussi
hop voilà alors là c'est on change
complètement d'échelle on a l'IM de VO
la même chose alors c'est effectivement
moi alors l'émission je me dis tiens je
regarde la je regarde la 3 je regarde la
4 on a l'impression que c'est un peu
alors si on zoome dedans on va voir
qu'il y a beaucoup beaucoup moins
d'étoiles en fait euh al c'est pas
évident pour vous mais de densité au là
là c'est un am globulaire donc là c'est
un am globulaire c'est dans notre VO
c'est dans notre Voie Lactée dans notre
galaxie c'est plus une galaxie
extérieure on est 100 fois plus proche
je crois ou 1 fois plus plus proche euh
non plus que ça on est à 8000 années
lumière je crois de mémoire on était à
on était à 1,4 million pour la galaxie
précédente ou 11 millions bon bref on
est l'heure de grandeur c'est qu'on est
beaucoup beaucoup plus près genre 100 ou
1000 fois plus près et il y a 1000 fois
moins d'étoiles d'accord donc et donc là
c'est un am globulaire un am globulaire
c'est un ensemble d'étoiles qui sont la
plutôt jeune
donc plutôt jeune et dont on dit
qu'elles sont une qu'elles ont une
métallicité faible c'estàd que c'est des
étoiles massives jeunes dans lesquelles
il y a qui ne résulent pas qui ont peu
de qui on peu former de d'éléments
lourds c'est dans les étoiles que se
forment les éléments lourds quand ils
explosent et cetera on va parenir toute
l'histoire de toute toute toute
l'évolution stellaire mais en gros c'est
des étoiles jeunes assez massives qui
sont formé dans un même nuage euh
moléculaire qui s'est effondré sur
lui-même donc le le le nuage de gaz et
de poussière c'est s'ffondre sur
lui-même dans toutes les petites zones
de densité euh petit à petit les les les
étoiles s'allument ça forme un nuage
d'étoil et et après voilà donc le le gaz
ensuite tout le gaz va dans les dans les
étoiles et dans les systèmes planétaires
et il ne reste entre guillemets que que
cette amaglobulaire
euh et donc là bah c'est des des
milliers d'étoiles he mais voilà on est
sur une échelle et du coup en terme de
de champ c'est la même chose entre
regarder un amaglobulaire euh à 7
distance là et regardez cette galaxie
nen qui est qui est 1000 fois plus loin
ça représente à peu près le même champ
oui c'est pour ça que ces deux images
finalement sont assez simaires
exactement elles se ressemblent beaucoup
alors que par nature elles sont très
différentes c'est deux objets qui n'ont
rien à voir qui sont pas du tout au
mêmees distance qui sont pas du tout au
mêmes
échellesit celle celle d'avant on le
devine un petit peu le côté plus diffus
on va dire defin plus moins ouais c'est
ça comment dire la on est on est à la
fois
plus comment expliquer c'est une zone
c'est comme si on était dans dans dans
l'image précédente et qu'on était dans
une toute petite partie de l'image
précédente et qu'on Zoomit zoom Zoomit
qu'on sur un am globulaire alors une
petite surdensité alors j'ai une
question dans le dans le chat de de Jean
rosé qui nous parle des aigrettes que
l'on voit sur les étoiles qui ont la
même forme que celle que l'on peut voir
sur les photos du télescope James web et
est-ce qu'il demande est-ce que le
miroir de cLID a la même forme que celui
de James web alors non il a pas la même
forme et si on ge vraiment précisément
on verra que les les les égrettes n'ont
pas exactement le le le la même forme
sur le JWST par exemple vous verrez
qu'il y a une espèce de diffraction les
les sur les les égrettes ont l'air un
petit peu comment dire rayé euh dans le
dans le sens voilà et ça c'est lié au
fait qu'il y a 16 miroirs par exemple
donc en fait il a des figures
secondaires de difffraction qu' y a pas
sur le CL parce que le CL il y a que un
miroir euh qui fait près un mtre mais
après les
c'est ça c'est les trait qui sont en
fait liés au qui sont liés en fait au au
support du du miroir en gros vous avez
un miroir principal vous avez un miroir
secondaire audessus il y a des il y a
des barres tout simplement pour les les
tenir ensemble et c'est ça qui produit
ces figures de ces figures de
difffraction
euh et donc elles sont pas exactement
elles sont il il a raison de de de
pointer elles sont spécifiques d'un
télescope h HM donc pour des des
spécialistes gens qui connaissent bien
en vous montrant une étoile en regardant
juste une étoile on peut en principe
retrouverel tlescope de quel télescope
il s'agit en reconnaissant certains
petits détails de l'rette et là
typiquement voilà si on regarde vraiment
précisément une égrette
de en zoomant un peu dessus on verra qu'
qu'elle a en fait des particularités
notamment c'est de figures secondaires
de diffraction qu'on voit pas sur sur
celle justement j'ai une question un peu
de prophè mais c'est quoi la différence
finalement entre Eid et James web alors
il y a plein de différences la première
différence c'est ils observent pas les
mêmes dans la même gamme de lumière
James web observe beaucoup plus dans
l'infrarouge donc des lumières moins
visibles à l'œil nu e cLID est beaucoup
plus dans le visible il a il a il voit
un petit peu dans l'infrarouge proche un
peu comme la vision de clit se rapproche
beaucoup plus de celle de
Hubble la deuxième différence c'est la
sensibilité la taille le James web il
est gigantesque son miroir principal il
fait 8 m c'est 8 fois plus grand du coup
il a une résolution
euh équivalente dans l'infrarouge mais
meilleure on va dire sur la partie qui
pourrait se toucher le James av une bien
meilleure
résolution par contre il peut son champ
est beaucoup plus réduit euh James il
est vraiment fait pour voir des des
objets individuels lointains des petites
images des champs très profonds par dans
dans une image comme comme celle qu'on a
vu sur le le le le lama de Percé web il
pourra avoir que une toute petite partie
de Lama mais il va aller il va les
zoomer dans une toute petite partie de
stama voir encore plus de galaxies et
comme il vont dans infrarouge il va PIR
avoir des objets qui sont encore plus
loin et donc il va pouvoir là où clit va
avoir on va dire jusqu'à 10
milliardsusquà 10 milliard d'années
lumière le James web pourra aller à 13,5
13,6 13,7 milliards d'années lumière qui
va voir plus loin plus profondément mais
par contre il est incapable incapable
d'effectuer une
image d'un coup aussi large est-ce que
c'est plus le est plus qualitatif et le
est plus quantitatif on peut le résumer
comm on pourrait le résumer comme ça
c'est
c'est après chacun sa manière bon le
James coûte plus cher clairement il doit
être 5 je 5 fois plus cher 5 si fois
plus
cher que l'autre il est
technologiquement il a fallu le déployer
parce que du coup il rentrait pas dans
un machin en terme de complexité
d'ingénierie le James SW est quand même
beaucoup plus
complexe et puis les les miroir pour
l'infrarouge c'est qui VI ces miroirs
dorés là et puis l'alignement des
miroire bref le jams est un objet plus
compliqué que le tescope de clin encore
mais en terme de performance après ils
ont ils jou pas la même catégorie donc
du coup c'est un peu compliqué de les
comparer il y a un télescope américain
de la NASA qui va sortir qui qui est
leur prochain grand télescope qui
s'appelle le roman télescope qui est à
peu
près le même objectif que cLID c'est il
a un champ très très large par rapport à
Hubble un peu moins large que cLID il
regarde lui aussi après dans le visible
un peu plus dans l'infrarouge donc il va
se comp l'étaé avecin mais il a
exactement le même objectif en tête
c'estàd cartographier la matière noire
l'énergie noire et là les performances s
rapprocheront je que la différence c'est
qu'il y en a un qui a un truc de relevé
systématique c'est vraiment ça la
différence il y en a un qui qui vraiment
va regarder le ciel systématiquement en
produisant en gros cette image là et
pour voir ce qui change entre les
surtout le ciel pour pour compter toutes
les non pour pour avoir toutes les
images toutes les les images des
galaxies possibles et et voilà et et en
fait de ça après il faut se faut faut
essayer de se dire que cette image là en
fait bon elle représent quelque chose
tout ce qui est en 3D l'objectif de cLID
ça va de prendre tout le ciel et ensuite
de faire des analyses pour arriver à
recréer euh cette cette trois dimensions
et l'objectif avait ensuite de découper
en tranche de profondeur l'univers et
donc de regarder entre 9 et des
milliards d'années lumière entre entre
entre 8 et 9 entre 7 et 8 à quoi
ressemblait la la la dispersion des
galaxies comment elles étaient réparties
selon des filaments comment étaient ces
filaments et cetera donc de regarder ça
à chaque époque et de regarder comment
ça évolué et en fait en faisant tout ça
c'est comme si on remonte le le film de
l'évolution de l'Univers depuis le Big
Bang et on va ensuite pouvoir comparer
ça aux simulations qu'on a et ce qui va
permettre de voir est-ce que nos
simulations marche et la simulation en
so on s'en fiche mais derrière la
simulation il y a des équations et donc
est-ce que les équations qu'on a et qui
font la simulation sont bonnes sachant
qu'on sait qu'elles ont forcément des
limites donc quelles sont les limites
comment est-ce qu'on va pouvoir aller
plus loin dans notre compréhension de
l'univers comment est-ce qu'on va
pouvoir aller au-delà de la relativité
générale d'instein pour expliquer ben ce
que c'est que cette matière noire et
cette énergie noire dont on a
l'impression que c'est des objets comme
ça mais en fait non c'est juste de de
paramètres qu'on qu'on ne comprend
pasprend en fait il y y a il y a il y a
donc énergie noire et et matière noire
pour qu'on comprenne c'est deux choses
qui composent l'univers mais ça pourrait
être beaucoup plus de il pourrait y
avoir énormément de trucs derrière ce ce
ce terme là c'est qu'en fait c'est on sa
sa pas en fait en fait c'est deux termes
pour dire on ne sait pas euh bien
comment évolue l'univers la matière noir
euh on a besoin d'elle parce qu'on s'est
rendu compte que les galaxies euh
tournaient trop vite sur elle-même par
rapport à ce qui est prévu par les
modèles de la relativité générale quand
on regarde le nombre d'étoiles qui les
composent leur masse apparente elle
tourne trop vite et donc on s'est rendu
compte que bon il manquait quelque chose
il y a il y a un facteur en trop dans
l'équation et pas il manque quelque
chose pour expliquer ça et on s'est
rendu compte que ben si on rajoutait un
truc théorique qui était donc quelque
chose d'invisible qui a de la masse euh
et qui n'agit que par les interactions
gravitationnelles c'estàdire que la
lumière la traverse c'est vraiment on
dit matière noir mais en fait c'est de
manière
transparente et qui a une et que si on
rajoutait ce ce ce truc entre guillemets
d'un coup tout marche les équations
nonont plus de problème le problème
c'est c'est quoi ce truc invisible qui a
une masse donc c'est un peu une facilité
scientifique de de dire matière noire
comme ça c'est comme si on avait rajouté
on avait dit on avait vu 1 + 1 é= 3 et
on s'est dit bah tiens on va rajouter un
+ 1 et ce + un on sait pas trop ce que
c'est mais ça marche d'accord ok voilà
et la l'énergie sombre c'est encore
autre chose c'est on s'est rendu compte
donc l'univers est en expansion très
bien c'est exactement ce que prévoit la
relativité générale que une fois qu'on
parle d'un Big Bang tout sauf qu'on
s'est rendu compte que l'expansion
s'accélérait que plus on regardait un
objet lointain plus s'éloignit vite de
nous et qu'en fait cette expansion elle
elle n'était pas linéaire mais voilà
elle éta elle était accélérée comme si
on comme si le ballon conffl de plus en
plus vite et du coup bah il on comprend
pas pourquoi donc quand on rajoute
pareil on peut rajouter un terme une
constante cosmologique dans dans les
dans dans l'équation d'instein et d'un
coup on retrouve mais c'est quoi qui
provoque ça
physiquement on sait pas donc on a on a
appelé ça énergie parce que B comme
c'est une accélération mais bon c'est
une énergie répulsive
euh dont on comprend pas bien ce qu'il y
a bah de quoi elle est composé vraiment
on a on a comment dire on a vraiment
aucune idée de ce que ça peut être donc
là l'idée avec ces ces observations ça
va c'est de de mieux contraindre en fait
bah quelle est la vitesse d'expansion de
l'univers comment elle a évolué avec le
temps pareil pour la matière noire
quelle est sa distribution dans
l'univers parce que cette matière noire
une fois qu'on la met dans le dans les
modèles cosmologiques elle donne une
espèce de matrice filamenteuse selon
laquelle s'organise les galaxies à très
grande échelle les amas les superamas ça
fait une espèce de comme une espèce de
toile d'araignée gigantesque et les
observations confirment ça c'estd que
quand on de plus en plus on se rend
compte bah oui voilà il y a
effectivement des des des des zones de
filaments sauf que c'est très dur à
cartographier systématiquement et c'est
ça que que fait Euclide c'est c'est
prendre toutes ces images du ciel tout
ces galaxies essayer de retrouver la
profondeur et essayer par des
statistique de retrouver bah quel est le
quelle est la la forme de cette quel est
la forme de cette matrice et et donc du
coup la réparation de matière noire et
la
répartition d'énergie noire enfin
comment la plutôt que la rtion d'énergie
noire voir
comment la l'expansion de l'Univers la
vitesse d'expansion de l'univers a
évolué avec le temps et on pense
que le but c'est de tirer ces données là
de de CL au final les résultats qu'on va
obtenir de CIN c'est un peu c'est un peu
c'est un peu peut-être désevant pour le
grand public mais ça va être des
chiffres des paramètres un peu
compliqués de densité de galaxie de dans
expansion al il y aura des belles images
mais les belles images sont pour les
astronomes c'est juste un un moyen si si
on dit que ça remet en cause Einstein
par exemple c'est c'est quand même pas
mal pour le grand public oui oui ah bah
non mais évidemment le le le le c'est
c'est juste que c'est c'est on va faire
un relevé du ciel complet et à la fin on
va tout mettre dans des dans des modèles
cosmologiques pour déduire des
paramètres et c'est ça qu'on va regarder
les les les astrophysiens souvent ils
regardent ils regardent pas de de belles
images ils regardent des courbes dans
des espaces de phase avec voilà ils
cherche un petit point une
pente ou alors même la valeur d'un
paramètre qui peut êtreement la et c'est
ça qui va pour eux être déterminant et
c'est ça qu'ils essayent de qui vont
essayer de sortir de ces données et
c'est des c'est des terras et des
terraas c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est
hallucinant le le la quantité de données
qui va être euh qui vont récupérer qui
vont devoir traiter pour essayer bah
justement faut s'imaginer voilà donc sur
une image comme ça il y a 100000
galaxies bah il faut déterminer à quelle
distance elles sont précisément quelle
est leur forme exacte est-ce qu'elles
ont été est-ce qu'elles sont un peu
déformées gravitationnellement et en
fait c'est des
algorithmes euh et de de statistiques
qui vont qui qui permettent de de voir
comment les les les galaxies sont sont
très très subtilement déformé à l'œil nu
on est incapable de voir que il y a une
déformation gravitationnelle c'est le le
vraiment c'est l'ordinateur qui voit
statistiquement qu'il y a des petites
déformations et que ça c'est lié à la
matière noire qui est sur la ligne de
Visé et cetera et cetera c'était
quelqueose un peu compliqué alors j'ai
j'ai une autre question de de de Jean
rosé qui nous demande sous quelle
échéance pouvons-nous espérer obtenir
les premiers résultats issus de
l'observation declide concernant la
matière noire et l'énergie noire sera
c'est décembre 2025 donc dès dès 2 ans
dans
dans 2 ans il y aura les premiers
résultats cosmologiques de clit donc qui
porteront pas sur l'intégralité des
données donc et les résultats finaux
justement c'est 8 ans 9 ans enfin sera
plutôt ouais ça je c que c'est 8 ans 8
ou 10 ans enfin c'est je crois que c'est
8 ans de relevé je vais pas dire de
bêtises je sais plus si c'est 8 ans de
relevé 8 ans dans le résultat mais c'est
l'ordre de grandeur quoi
euh après
euh pour le grand public je pense que
dans 2 ans on aura voilà on on aura des
on reparlera sur ce plateau plau
cont ça ça va beaucoup nourrir la
communauté des des
[Musique]
théoriciens et donc du coup et puis et
puis il faut voir aussi que donc je
paris de la Legacy science la science
qui sera faite à partir des images en
fait les images sont gardés pendant 1 an
de manière propriétaire par les a donc
c'est pour ça que que en gros il y a un
an de relevé et la publié en 2025 et à
ce moment-là en 2025 quand la
premièretie du catalogue sera ouverte
aux données le temps faire le le voilà
les petit à petit les les données seront
données comme ça au aux scientifiques
qui pourront probablement faire d'autres
d'autres analyses plus fines sur des
structures de l'univers et cetera il
faut voir qu' avec GAA qui qui est un
peu l'équivalent de de Lesa euh pour les
étoiles de la Voie Lactée euh on a
cartographié des milliards d'étoiles
dans la Voie Lactée il y a encore des
aujourd'hui des publications qui sortent
sur des courons d'étoil l'histoire de la
voie lacté
comment elle a été comment il y a des
des collisions par le passé qui ont créé
des courants d'étoiles comment le disque
un plus moins penché sur les les étoiles
qui tourn autour du centre de la vocté
enfin bref il y a plein plein de choses
super intéressantes qui nous renseignent
sur notre histoire un peu local
galactique al il y a encore une image
dont on n pas parlé et que je vais
réafficher ici voilà c'est c'est c'est
celle-ci c'est cette image alors qui a
l'air beaucoup plus on va dire
objectivement très belle
ouais qu'est-ce qu'on voit sur cette
image je je je je soupçonne qu'elle est
qu'elle est qu'elle est là pour faire
joli non non elle est elle a elle elle
fait aussi l'objet d'un programme
scientifique d'études de formation des
étoiles c'est c'est ce qu'on appelle ça
c'est un nuage moléculaire donc ça c'est
dans notre Voie Lactée aussi comme Lama
globulaire on est sur les mêmes échelles
un peu que le lama globulaire un peu
plus proche
encore et et
là ce qu'on regarde c'est une zone de
formation d'étoiles c'est ce qui se
passe avant euh l'AM globulaire c'est
vraiment le le nuage dans lequel se
forment les étoiles et donc là les
scientifique bah regarder des tout
petits détails sur le le on quand on
zoome on voit des filaments de gaz très
fins enfin voilà on voit la structure
vraiment très très détaillée typiquement
pour ce genre d'étude le J WST à priori
est meilleur euh parce que lui il va
aller pouvoir regarder des détails très
précis et cetera vendant zoomer dans des
des dans des sous-régions là euh
l'avantage qu'on a euh avec le clit
c'est qu'on voit bien le contexte du
nuage on voit qu'il est illuminé alors
c'est assez beau d'ailleurs par par le
dessus par une une étoile qui s'appelle
altinac je crois altinac qui une étoile
très brillante proche de la ceinture
d'oriion
euh et qui éclaire par le dessus comme
ça elle est hors champ parce que si elle
était dans le champ elle illuminerait le
elle éblouirait en fait le télescope
donc c'est pour ça qu' le champ est
juste en dessous de cette étoile là on
la voit pas euh et donc c'est la nbuse
de la tête de cheval qui est très qui
qui un objet très connu et je pense
c'est pour pour ça qu'il étaé choisi
aussi qui a un objet un peu iconique qui
était observé par rubble le JWST en a
aussi fait une image parce que ben voilà
c'est c'est vrai que c'est une c'est
très beau quoié c'est joli c'est joli
c'est beau les nuages moléculaires c'est
ce qui fait les images les plus belles
parce que ben il y a c'est un peu opaque
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de poussière
dedans et de gaz donc ça laisse pas
passer toute la lumière qu'il y a
derrière donc ça donne beaucoup de
relief à l'image moi ce que je trouve
très beau si on peut dézoomer un peu sur
celle-là justement qu' qu'on voit
peut-être pas trop sur les autres bah
c'est le voilà c'est c'est l'espèce de
ci de ciel on dirait une aurore Boréal
quoi c'est pas du tout une aurore Boréal
fait pas dire ce que j'ai pas dit mais
mais mais c'est ça ça c'est ce à quoi ça
me fait penser espèce de de grand
filament de lumière donc je sais pas
exactement ce que c'est je je présume
que c'est c'est illuminé par des étoiles
jeunes
euh mais voilà je trouve ça très beau et
ça c'est quelque chose voilà qu'on qu'on
voit peut-être moins sur les sur les
image de JWST ou de ou de Hubble parce
qu'on a on a on a moins ce ce champ
large donc c'est un peu ça ça que ça
apporte cette espèce de de vision de de
cette partie de l' tête de cheval dans
un contexte un peu plus un peu plus
large mais je pense clairement que ils
sont dit que pour communiquer ce serait
très bien ils ont ils ils ont pas tort
du tout
hein il faut aussi des belles images et
ça montre que eclid c'est un satellite
donc de cosmologie donc qui est vraiment
fait pour faire de la science dure mais
l'instrument est tellement incroyable
que il serait capable de faire aussi des
tas et des tas de oui puis il faut quand
même communiquer aussi il faut quand
même montrer au grand public ce que ça
fait et et et et on ne se fait pas on va
dire la comment dire on ne fait pas
l'économie de faire une très belle im
pour donner envie aux gens de
s'intéresser à la science derrière ex Il
est pas impossible d'ailleurs que dans
les année là de relevé systématique il
est ponctuellement ce qu'on appelle des
observations opportunistes c'est-à-dire
ben je sais pas un moment où le relev
pas possible ou il il y a plus machin et
ben du coup on pointe vers une autre
zone pour faire une quelques belles
images ou quelqu quelques im enfin
belles images quelques belles images de
zones qui sont d'intérêt
scientifique voir alors ça c'est pas
c'est moins clair mais mais voilà on
parle beaucoup de l'astronomie
multimessager maintenant quand il y a
quelque chose qui est détecté au sol un
événement particulier une Nova une
supernova une kilonova ou des zones
gravitationnelles on essaie de pointer
plein de télescopes de différentes
capacités sur le l'événement en question
pour essayer de de voir si on arrive à
et peut-être que Clide aussi dans ce
contexte là en cas d'événement rela
ement proche exceptionnel ou dans une
galaxie voilà il a cette capacité de
pointage de de d'avoir l'environnement
dans lequel se situer le phénomène qui
est
assez unique et peut-être c'est aussi
quelque chose qui se fera après les 8
années de de service il est possible que
il y ait d'autres recherches des des
enfin voilà c'est un instrument qui est
vraiment chouette scientifiquement c'est
vraiment le côté énergis matière sombre
qui est qui est étonnant et là ben voilà
c'était c mon truc bah ça reste un
télescope avant tout et qu'un télescope
ça peut faire de super belles images
surtout quand c'est dans l'espace c'est
sûr on imagine Jean rosé qui nous dit
alnitac pour les pour lesac merci voilà
et Patrick il me demande la différence
avec James web al on a déjà répondu à
cette question peut-être r répéter
rapidement la différence avec James web
la différence avec James web c'est que
le champ est est immensément plus large
que ce que fait James web James web si
vous voulez il fait une en il Zoomit par
exemple làdedans il Zoomit il pouvait
surtout zoomer dans dans un petit car
alors il peut faire une image si vous
voulez de ça mais il va falloir qu'il
face en mosaïque en plein de fois et
donc du coup ça va lui prendre vachement
de temps là il a fallu une heure c'est 1
heure de pause cette image d'accord
c'est ça la la l'énorme fort c'estd que
Hubble va pouvoir vous faire une une
image de la tête de cheval mais ça va
être une mosaïque en fait de je sais
pas peut-être quelques centaines
d'heures d'observation donc plusieurs
jours consacrés à ça pour produire cette
image là il arrive il est là tac c'est
voilà c'est c'est c'est assezriffant
donc ça c'est c'est toute la partie de
Clide qu'on peut qui est pas visible qui
est un peu caché c'est la rapidité là
toutes les images qu'on a vu euh percé
c'est 5h et toutes les autres c'est
1hure voilà c'est c'est c'est assez
fantastique et c'est ce qu'il faut parce
qu'ils vont faire le le l'image qu'on a
vu de percer euh il y en a 30000 en gros
qui vont être faites comme ça donc il
vaut mieux que ça aille vite pour
prendre des photos ben il faut que ça
aille vite ouais 300 si on fait 30000
fois euh 5 he je vous laisse le calculle
je le calcul exactement merci beaucoup
tristop en tout cas d'avoir été avec
nous pour décrypter ces images